imaginez vous êtes chez vous et vous
recevez un code à l'intérieur de colis
se trouve une boîte une boîte comme ça
arrive souvent
sauf qu'à l'intérieur de la boîte il ya
une information très très spécial cette
information là il y a que vous qui
pouvait la connaître donc vous ouvrez la
boîte vous la poser et à l'intérieur de
la boîte vous vous apercevez que vous
pouvez ranger lokoli le colis dans la
boîte que vous avez reçue c'est quelque
chose de complètement impossible et ça
c'est peut-être l'indication que vous
êtes dans un rêve
et justement aujourd'hui on va parler
des rêves lucides un rêve du site comme
vous l'avez sûrement compris c'est un
rêve où le rêveur a conscience qu'il est
en train de rêver ça veut pas forcément
dire qu'il maîtrise son rêve mais ça
veut dire qu'il a conscience du moment
qu'il est en train de vivre que c'est un
rêve que c'est un monde onirique un des
précurseurs dans la matière qui font
encore aujourd'hui de office de
référence puisqu'il faut encore des
conférences là-dessus publie des livres
là dessus c'est stéphane laberge qui en
1981 a mené tout un processus
scientifique a pour pouvoir vérifier
analysé que des personnes étaient en
état de rêve lucide et pour pouvoir
amener aussi toute une méthodologie pour
accéder aux réussites facilement vous
rêvez et je rêve dans le sommeil
paradoxal c'est le moment où on rêve on
rêve une dizaine de fois par nuit un bon
rêveur est capable de se souvenir de 4 à
5 de ses rêves et bien souvent on se
souviens d'aucun rêve parce qu'on ne
fait pas l'effort de s'en rappeler le
rêve lucide on peut être subi mais peut
être aussi contrôlé à plus ou moins
grand degré par exemple moi quand je
fais un rêve lucide j'arrive à contrôler
mes actions ce que je vais faire un mais
pas forcément quelles sont les personnes
qui vont intervenir ou qu'elles vont
être leur réaction ou quand vous dans
quel décor je me trouve je sais qu'il y
en a qui arrivent à ça mais c'est plus
compliqué c'est juste sort de dire que
tout n'est pas forcément contrôlables
rêve lucide et tout n'est pas forcément
non plus subi que l'intérêt du rêve
lucide c'est encore plus qu un kiff
ça permet au sens propre de réaliser ses
rêves ça permet de rentrer directement
en contact avec son inconscient c'est
presque comme un sport ça demande un
petit peu d'entraînement je vais vous
donner trois astuces de stéphane laberge
et de ses équipes qui permettent de
rentrer plus facilement dans un état de
rêve lucide et volontairement et une
astuce qui met plus personnelle que j'ai
eu pas retrouver ailleurs pour le moment
première astuce il faut être capable de
vérifier dans un rêve qu'on est en train
de rêver pour ça il faut prendre le
clean le faire également quand on est
dans la réalité il ya plein de
techniques qui existent qui est par
exemple faire sonner un réveil toutes
les deux ou trois heures en temps la
réalité je parle qu'à ce moment-là
interpréter les signes
de soi pour voir si on est en train de
rêver ou pas je m'étais dit plutôt que
de faire sonner un réveil qui ne
sonnerait en plus pas dans mon rêve je
vais prendre un objet récurrents qu'est
ce que je regarde le plus dans une
journée mon téléphone
du coup à chaque fois que je regardais
mon téléphone j'ai essayé d'analyser si
j'étais en train de rêver ou pas mais
après je me suis rendu compte de quelque
chose c'est que dans mes rêves j'ai eu
mon téléphone arabe moi je ne téléphone
pas dans mes rêves
donc j'ai fait l'inversé analyser mes
rêves pour voir ce que je faisais
souvent et alors on va savoir pourquoi
moi souvent dans mes rêves je rentre
chez moi une de mes récurrent je rentre
chez moi mais mon chez moi peut être
2000 forme différent ça peut être une
toile et de temps ça peut être un palet
mais je rentre chez moi donc maintenant
à chaque fois que j'ouvre la porte de
chez moi à chaque fois que je rentre
chez moi dans la réalité
je me demande d'où je viens est ce que
je sais exactement où je viens et
comment je suis arrivé ici je regarde
l'heure je tourne la tête je regarde
l'heure et je vérifie si leur s'écoule
normalement et j'essaie de comprendre
quel moment de la journée on est pour
voir si tout est cohérent et si je sais
ce que je vais faire après et le fait de
faire ça dans la réalité à chaque fois
que j'ouvre la porte de chez moi ça fait
que quand j'entre dans un rêve et que je
rentre chez moi en rêve
parfois c'est pas tout le temps parfois
le même réflexe se remet en place
autant vous dire que la première fois
que ça c'est fait je me suis réveillé
pas de panique peu plus tôt d'excitation
fait d'être j'étais en train de prendre
conscience que je rêvais et c'est
vraiment pas à chaque fois en fait on
nous dit qu'un bon un bon rêveur lucide
ça va lui arriver quatre à cinq fois
dans le mois
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
rare le deuxième bonne astuce c'est le
soir quand vous vous endormez vous
décidez que vous allez faire un rêve
lucide
vous vous détendez bien dans le lit vous
vous dites une phrase du genre ce soir
je vais prendre conscience que je rêve
le fait de le verbaliser c'est un
message très fort que vous envoyez à
votre inconscient et la troisième astuce
c'est celle de jude ajouté alors j'ai
ajouté c'est un mot qui n'existe pas
quand même d'un mot qui a été inventé en
fait c'est le fait de retourner dans ses
rêves d'un peu comateux et puis vous
replonger un petit peu dans le rêve
c'est sa jupe jetez donc essayer quand
vous vous réveillez vous n'avez pas à
vous lever de bien vous remémorer le
rêve de vous remettre dedans mais de
commencer à essayer de décider des
actions que vous allez y faire avant d'y
replonger et d'une manière générale
essayez de vous rappeler de vos rêves
c'est à dire que quand vous vous
réveillez le matin prôné une à deux
minutes vraiment dans le lit pour
essayer de consolider comme ça tous vos
souvenirs de rêve c'est pas le
brouillard se dissipe et plus vous allez
prêter d'attention rêve que vous allez
prêter d'attention à vos rêves que vous
aller facilement faire des rêves lucides
et laterrière technique que j'ai trouvé
qu'il fonctionne bien sur moi quand je
rêve je me vois souvent comme si je me
filmer on va dire je me vois depuis
l'extérieur et j'assiste aux scènes sais
pas si c'est votre cas
dites le nous dans les commentaires
d'ailleurs ça m'intéresserait de fois ci
je suis le seul mec je loue comme ça
donc dans le lit le soir quand je
m'amuse à imaginer les rêves que je
pourrais faire ou que je me rappelle les
rêves que je faisais j'essaie vraiment
de m'imaginer où je me vois la première
personne comme dans la vie normale c'est
à dire je vois mes deux bras je vois
mais demain je vois mes jambes je vois
mes pieds je me vois à l'intérieur de
mon corps et je crois que c'est ce qui
m'a aidé le plus à faire des rêves
lucides si ça vous intéresse et que vous
voulez aller plus loin que ça il ya des
formations en urologie ou des formations
en rêve lucide des stages en général ça
dure quatre ou cinq jours joule mais
également dans le descriptif de la vidéo
un excellent site qui s'appelle attrape
songe
il ya un des dernier livre de bernard
werber qui en parle qui s'appelle le
sixième sommeil il ya un très très bon
roman je ne saurais que trop vous
recommander aussi le livre de stéphane
laberge est à l'origine de tout le
travail sur le rêve lucide et en europe
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
très très connu en fait dans d'autres
civilisations mais chez nous c'est un
typiquement parlant c'est lui la source
il a écrit plein de livres il donne
encore vraiment beaucoup de conférences
mais pour moi le plus intéressant c'est
celui qui l'a écrit ce rappel ces
veillées en rêvant je vole mais aussi
est un des livres préférés sur le sujet
parce qu'il est très très complet et on
sent vraiment que l'auteur a l'habitude
et que c'est pas un ramassis
d'informations glanées mais un vrai
ressenti c'est le guide des rêves
lucides prenait le contrôle de vos rêves
que je vous mets également dans le
package du descriptif
merci d'avoir regardé ce master class un
petit peu différent j'espère qu'il vous
aura plu si c'est le cas faites le nous
savoir en laissant un petit pouce en
l'air et puis je le mérite ce pouce en
l'air parce que vous savez quoi parce qu
on est samedi matin et je me suis couché
tard hier soir je possède toute la
semaine et je me suis levé pour faire la
vidéo aujourd'hui et je voulais qu'elle
soit de qualité oui monsieur et je le
prouve
plus que je suis encore au café je pense
d'ailleurs que j'ai beaucoup moins
d'énergie que d'habitude dans sa vidéo
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir en cliquant sur
le petit logo qui en haut à droite ou
sous la vidéo et rendez vous demain à 11
heures pour le prochain mentale blogs
chats